你先有什么？
只要他好，你都可以。
让它生根发芽，以前得有个种子呀，对吧？我们下篇我们知道得有个种子呀。
来第三种种子。
第一种种子人物设定，第二种种子激励事件。好吧，第三种种子。
叫什么呢？
又是一个新词儿，但是你们不要害怕，很容易理解，叫过激行为。
就是一个明显的过激行为。
也可以成为你这个故事的。
支点或者是你下手的起点。
或者说你整个。
这个盘子的半壁江山。
过激的行为。
啥叫过激行为？
不要觉得这是个新词儿，不要发懵，我再给你说，我再给你起起一个名字，你就明白了。
过激行为又叫。
二次动作。
还是新词吗？
有有点熟悉了。
动作呀。
动作昨天说过。
八要素里面有没有动作？动作接在欲往下面。
啥叫动作？为了实现欲望而采取的行动，实现欲望而采取的行动。
二次动作是什么？
就是为了实现欲望，采取了一次行动，失败了。回来之后。
第二次去采取的行动。那第二次次去第二次去采取的行动不就会是过激行为吗？
你看到一个姑娘哇，太漂亮了。
想想得到第一次第一次什么行为？
追求人家呀。
追求人家才是正常的一次行为吗？
不同意嫌你丑。
回来之后。
对吧生气了，绑架他。
过激啦过激行为，二次动作就是过激行为，知道吗？第一次失败之后回来琢磨琢磨再去，二次动作就是过激行为。你有一个好的过激行为。
也可以成为一个。
故事的起点也可以成为我们下手的地方。
也可以成为就是你创意的火种。
我们说那非得是二次动作。
你一次动作是惯性动作呀。
明白吗？依次动作是惯性动作，依次动作不要搞创意。
依次动作搞创意，你这个戏就不好看了。
依次动作是所有观众都能想到的那个动作。
顺撇而大。
那过激行为有什么片子？
典型的。
国际行为支撑起来骗子。
有个片子非常好看。
有个片子非常好看，叫录取通知书。
交录取通知书。
讲什么？
讲的呃几个高中毕业的。
高中毕业生功课很差。
没考上大学。
呃，是一个美国片儿，在美国都没考上大学，连社区大学都没考上，应该是学习足够差。
然后呢呃不好意思跟家里说。
或种种原因吧，几个人可能原因不一样，种种原因吧都没办法跟家里说。然后呢，几个人一商量。
伪造了录取通知书。
这个这个找街边办证嘛，给一人刻了一个录取通知书，几个人一块办的，所以就。
起了一个名，这样串工也好串呀。哎，你儿子也考上这个呃这个呃哈尔格旗这个商学院，对吧？内蒙古自治区、哈尔格旗商学院呢，就就每个人录取通知书都一样，都是假的。
啊造完这个事儿录取通知书以后呢，这几个人呢就等于是混过去了。但是好死不死呢，这几个孩子的家长他们没考虑一个事，那你丑媳妇总得见公婆呀。这几个孩子家长到开学那天说我们送你去上学吧。
那。
那他们就。
一不做二不休，不是伪造录取通知书吗？不是是学校名都一样吗？伪造一个大学，他们租了一个地方，定点大牌子，然后再招呼点所有没考上大学的那些他们的同学，甚至还有什么一些流浪汉什么的。
全部到这个地方来伪装成一个学校。
伪装成一个学校。
这个这个糊弄他们的爸妈，就故事走向呢是往下走是他们最后真的在这个学校开始雇老师，开始办学收学费，就凭这个学校的基础建设跟师资取得了一个类似于。
这个技术学院的。
一个资质。
就是很正能量的一个结局。
这就是一个典型的非常过激的行为。
的创意。
想上大学。
看到一个姑娘很漂亮，这去追一样的道理啊，我想上大学。
想上大学，我的行为是什么？
好好学习，你去考呀，你好好学习，你去考大学呀，这才是第一次行为。然后去考没考上回来了，回来他妈的要采取二次行为，二次行为不就过激了吗？我造一个大学这个过激大学这个过激行为，我造一个大学就非常有创意。
非常有创意。所以说这个电影它的起点一定是这个过激行为，是他的起点。来，我讲这个故事，你觉得很有意思，但你根本就没有问我，哎，那主角那几个孩子是什么样的人？
明白吗？在这里不重要。
企眼在这儿很漂亮。
明白吗？
过激行为也可以作为过作为一个系的企业。
那你说过激行为二次动作嗯，还有例子吧？还有哪个戏是以二次动作过激行为构成的构成指点的呢？
有一个我们大家都看过的戏，它整个戏全是由二次动作构建的。
几百上千级全都一样。
比如说。
明天要考试了。
啊在这学习啊，死活学不会。
死活学不会，这是依次行为啊，明天要考试，我得好好学习，这是依次行为吧。死活学不会。然后哆啦A梦哆啦A梦，我该怎么办呀？哆啦A梦拿出记忆面包往那个卷子上一一拍，然后吃掉，一下全都会了。大熊一下全都会了。结果第二天考试前拉一掏屎。
还没了，对吧？大学，然后今天又又出去了，跟那个胖虎打棒球，打不过人家，没有运动天赋，被胖虎扁了一顿，还把还让人把手套抢走了。
啊回来有哆啦A梦哆啦A梦，我这棒球我打不过炮鼓，对吧？一次行为失败了呀，哆啦A梦哆啦A梦帮帮我哆啦A梦哎是，人拿出一个什么高科技手套戴上之后就打球就无敌，是吧？整部哆啦A梦。
全是大熊的二次行为，你去看。
对吧所以我告诉你，过激行为二次动作。
也是一个很好的创意切入点。
你如果能找到这个。
太公。
开始搞对吧？而且半壁江山也有了。
就刚才我跟你们说的录取通知书。
那个二次动作那个戏基本有了。
对吧主角至于是三个还是4个，是两男两女还是四男三女？
我们说这是又是一种。
又是一种支点下手的点。
来第四。
我们说悬念。
悬念悬念也是一个很古老很传统的支点呀，对吧？
带悬念的故事往往是人。
愿意听的。所以你一个故事，如果你先有了一个好的悬念，也是完全可以支撑下去的。
完全可以支撑下去。
悬念也不是一个新词，也是咱们八要素里面的吧。
我说是问题的一种。
八要素那个世界的第一个不是核心问题吗？核心问题不是会产生悬念吗？能不能行不行，死不死，对吧？
这不就是个悬念吗？
以悬念为为支撑的片子，比如说危机的片子。
灾难的片子。
都是悬念的呀。
你就会在哎呀，他们会不会死掉啊，那么危机型的片子，灾难型片子，你能想到一个好的危机，好的灾难。
对吧比如说我们说那个呃生死时速，生死时速绝对是先有悬念的。
先有这个悬念的生死时速的核心是什么？大家记得吗？很老的一个电影呃，呃Kiano瑞s那个电影。
基诺里维斯。
基洛里维斯那个生死时速。
他讲什么讲一个公交车上被人装了一个炸弹，然后呢，这个这个装炸弹的这个坏蛋。
很坏的这炸弹怎么装的？装在仪表盘处用仪表盘触发，就是你的速度，你这公交车的速度，比如说低于。
8090低于一个速度。
就会引爆。
一车人车上好多人，一车人就死。
就是这么一个。
对。
这个设定。
它就是一个悬念设定。
这个炸台会不会爆炸？什么时候爆价？他们怎么样才能一直开这么快，没油了怎么办？
对吧或者是遇到堵车怎么办？
或者是撞车了怎么办？
对不对？
全是悬念。
这个电影就有吧。
就一定觉得你就开始就觉得好看了，他是不是基诺基诺里维斯都不重要了，甚至你到现在都没有产生一种。哎，基诺里维斯在里面演什么，你都没去想这个事情不重要，他可以是个特工，可以是个警察，可以就是一个普通的大巴司机。
但然基诺李维斯长那么帅眼，大巴司机是肯定不太现实的对吧？但是大家可以还可以演一个什么退伍兵啊什么，反正肯定是个强人嘛。
这这种就是这个。
悬念篇悬念篇啊像这个就是这个炸弹啊，这种悬念是是很容易理解的啊，还有很多悬念篇。
就是你可以下手的点，比如说假身份。
假身份是很好的一种啊，假身份是我个人是非常喜欢的一种一种一种悬念设定方式。
就是你这个片子如果从一个假身份入手，也是迅速的就能。
进入故事节奏。
比如说。
让子弹飞。
让子弹废。
就是一个假身份嘛。
他是个马匪。
他捡了一张。
那个那个上任的委任状，然后就去哎，咱先当个咱就当个县长吧。
那上来他这个身份。
就是个危机。
对吧它就是一个悬而什么叫悬念？悬而未决的定时炸弹呀。
悬而未觉的定时炸弹呀。
那这些假身份随时被破，还有那个金装律师。
有一个美剧叫金装律师，写的非常之好，非常之好看。咱们国内某一个律师系。
很严重的借鉴了他。当然我不知道人家两个戏是具体什么关系啊，咱就不去说了。金装律师里面他的男一号。
就是一个。
假律师。
他是怎么是一个假律师呢？他开场戏是。
他被警察追。
被警察追。
因为他是个犯大麻的，大麻这是个deer。
然后呢，被警察追的走投无路，看到一帮人。
然后就混到那个人群中，谁知道那一帮人那个人群呀。
是。
排队面试律师。
的一个队伍。
然后就到他了，到他了，他就进去了。蔑试他的律师就是另外一个男一号。
这个人呢是个不按常理出牌的人。
结果他呢无心应应聘，他呢又是个不按厂理出牌的人，叮咣几下之后，他看中他了。
他说你小子可以啊，有个性，我喜欢来留下，我就要你了。
但是他是个毒贩，他没有这个法学院的毕业资质呀。
但是你想他在社会上混，他会造假呀，他一看这份工作不错呀，赚钱很多呀，我就不用贩毒了。然后他就伪造了一个这个这个身份。
假身份就是你危机开场，悬念开场，悬而未决。你这个戏。
也也有起点了，而且也有个7788了。
我们说还有一个那个美国有一个美剧，具体名字我是想不起来了一个男人也是跟马走日差不多意思。
去到一个小镇。
捡了一个一个警长被人杀害了，他捡了这个警长的伟人状。
去当一个。
去这个小镇应聘当警察，这个小镇反正没人见过他。
一个假警察。
反正一个假警察嘛，对吧？也是一个假身份。我说所以我说这个假身份这个东西啊。
也是一个很好的悬念，对吧？我说还有一种悬念的设定方法，除了假设啊，还有个时间锁。
时间锁也很好用了，时间锁其实就我们说悬而未决的炸弹嘛，时间锁其实就是定时炸弹，对吧？定时炸弹灰姑娘那个就是定时炸弹呀，你12点之前你必须你12点就就现出原形，那么你。
观众所有的心都揪在这个12点这个这个问题上呀，都揪在这个12点这个问题上，就是悬念片子。好吧，你有一个好的悬念，你这个你又你又有地方下手了。
这也是一个。
不错的。
下手的地方。然后第五还有一个。
一个好的环境。
个好的环境也可以成为你优先思考的一个点。我们说我们列的这些点啊是啥意思呢？就是你不知道该怎么创造一个故事的时候，你可以以点带面。
下手的一个地方，就说你有一个点精彩了，你这个故事就大差不差。
就这5个地方你如果搞精彩一个地方，你就大差不差。
那我们说这个环境啥意思？
啥叫缓节？
就是这个环境本身一听就让你觉得。
那这个故事。
有味道了，比如说荒岛荒岛余生呀，荒岛余生这个环境来，我告诉你，有一个人困在荒岛上了。
一个人，然后他在这个荒岛上生活了。
好几年。
先天呢你会你就会想知道他他吃什么，他他穿什么，他他怎么生活的荒岛，对吧？这个环境首先吸引人。
侏罗纪公园。
侏罗纪公园里面的恐龙全都活了，一家人困在侏罗纪公园里。
这个环境我们说修女也疯狂。
对吧一个妓女。
困在了一个修道院。
他很粗糙的呀。
啊，他不算一个妓女啊，算一个歌女呃算一个。
公主不。
嗯嘿。
KTV的啊KTV的黑人歌女。
困在了一个全是白人老太太的。
老处女白人老老修女的一个修道院。
等于这个环境很要他命，不能抽烟。
啊，不能扯淡，不能呃不能那个那个出去玩。
不能大声说话。
这个环境我们一听哎。
是吧是可以的，是可以呃是可以有点意思的。
飞跃疯人怨。
一个正常人。
在精神病院在精神病院里，一个正常人在精神病院里。
环境。
我们说这个环境又又又是你新搞出来的一个东西吗？
也不是。
环境我我昨天也说过。
环境是八要素里面，我说。
障碍。
里面的一种。
八要素里面的障碍，我说障碍有多种多样。但是我给大家提供一个思路，按照一个顺序写环境的障碍，对手的障碍。
自己的障碍。
所以这个环境其实是障碍中的一种。
其实这些东西都没跳出八要素，都是八要素中的一部分，我只是把它。
细出来拎出来，告诉你这些地方可以用，可以让你用来下手。
可以让你当做故事的起点，好吧，第一。
一个。
有意思的人设，一个有意思的身份，可以成为你这个故事的半壁江山。我们昨天搞过一下那个警察。
人设出来以后。
心里就不慌了，觉得这个故事有成了一半。
然后第二，激励事件，这个好像是应该是就是在这5个当中占比最大的一个。
你有一个好的激励事件，好的干扰事件。
你这个故事啊。
7788了。
我们说干扰事件有口诀，小人物出大事儿，大人物贪小事儿。
过激行为。
过激行为也叫二次动作。
对吧怎么创造呢？就是你有一个欲望。
你的惯性动作。
以外，失败了以后，你会采取一个什么样的过激动作？这个过激动作。
往往就是有戏的，往往。
就是有创意的，可以是有创意的，就可以成为你的起点。
呃，第四，一个好的悬念。
好的悬而未决的炸弹。
也可以勾起别人的观看欲吧。
那就可以成为你的创作欲啊。
那他就是有比如说一个假身份。
一个时间锁。
或者是一个。
秘密。
对吧一个呃呃疑问不知道是谁杀的。
然后5、环境。
你能创造出一个环境，创造出一个粗细的环境，创造出一个矛盾重重的环境。
也可以成为你一个故事。因为我们说你看有很多人讲故事说，哎，我给你讲一个。
什么什么样的人的故事。
我一个人。
也有的人喜欢讲故事，哎，我跟你讲一个农场的故事，他喜欢搞环以从环境入手，对吧？
这5点可以大作为大家。
写自己第一个故事下手的地方。
这是我精心提炼出来。
精心提炼出来。因为我写故事的时候写一个新的故事，不知道从哪写。
而且我告诉你，你找一个起点，你把这一个起点写好了，你这个故事就合格了。
就合格了。
当然啊，你说比如说。
我这个故事我先有了一个悬念，这悬念哎呀，我做的挺漂亮。
然后呢，我。
补其他5个的时候，我顺便把人设也写的。
很有劲儿。
等于你有两个支点，那你这个故事就可以就开始精彩了，你懂我意思吧？就开始精彩了。当然你说我神通广大。
我写了3个。
漂亮的。
八要素里面我把三个。
搞起来了，我跟你说，那你这个故事基本上可以拍了。
收拾收拾可以拍嘛。
四个你说八要素我有四个强点，四个强烈强的强大的支点。
我跟你说，你有可能就是天才。
你说我这八要素里面。
我有5个。
很有创意。
那你就打住吧。
别写那么多，为什么啊？
我们说这8个要素呀，你要一半是海水，一半是火焰。
你可能不理解这个事儿啊。
这么说吧，就是你写一个故事，你不能完全跳脱惯性思维。
你要有创意，但你不能完全挑出惯性思维。
明白吗？
八要素里面。
有4个有创意。
有4个呢。
符合观众的预期。
符合观众的预期非常重要。因为一个故事啊，你讲出来的时候啊，你其实。
对观众是有一定的承诺的。
比如说我们随便说。
大荣遇小事儿。
这个故事我们说。
一个黑社会大哥，我们就讲那个黑社会大哥那个一个黑社会大哥，一个大头。
好啊。
上高中。
我们说我们用那个咱们那个朋友检验说哎。
我也你讲个故事，一个黑社会大哥啊。
去上高中的故事，回到高中校园的故事，他一定感兴趣。他也说啊，那你给我讲讲，但是。
同时。
他的大脑里面就开始产生一些。
对这个故事的期待。
比如说他会想。
啊，一个黑社会大哥那。
肯定能打呀。
他来到一个高中。
这个高中会有自己的。
学生打嗝。
对吧这个学生大哥一上来，那肯定来新人了呀。
那肯定要立威呀。
要告诉他这个地盘谁的呀？
所以这个大哥会削这个大佬。
对吧而且削的第一次两次，这个大佬为了隐藏身份是不敢还手的。
对吧。
这就是你朋友对于你讲的这个故事，你虽然没讲这个情节，他的想象，他的期待。
你得满足他。
你一点也不满足，每一条都说我要跳出框框，我要写我的创意。
呃，不行。
他会难过的。
这个我们回头。
详细给大家说这个尺度怎么把握，呃，也不能光我说。
其实得你们自己慢慢去体会，关于这个把握，什么叫一半是海水，一半是火焰。
你既得完成给观众的承诺。
又得有创意。
所以我一般建议啊故事八要素。
四个创新。
这个胸围。
一半一半好吧，具体怎么一半一半。
我不会撂下来。
咱们回头详细说。
啊，下课。